what is going on there reject nation we
got the return of juan humphrey back in
the channel and of course we got andrew
gordon one of our other big comic book
movie aficionados here today john how's
phil be back it feels amazing andrew how
do you feel i feel great it's a mustache
yeah that's a mustache all right guys
well we got ourselves an i am groot
official trailer official it's only one
minute long this show comes out in like
five days it comes out in like like two
weeks or something like that but hey you
know it's comic con so we got some
goodies coming our way if you can leave
a like i know you can do that subscribe
and click that notification bell because
we obviously got more coming up but yeah
let's just hop into this and see what's
going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
damn right you are buddy
poop that thing out
[Music]
oh cool
[Laughter]
marvel goes big on their first trailer
to come out of comic con
man
no expense spared
uh that just looks uh super duper
adorable man it's like a little little
groot he's a teenager now right or no
where would we leave off at 4 11 forget
he's a teenager
yeah he's a teenager but to have you
know baby groot uh super freaking
adorable from guardians 2 of course and
uh it kind of feels like it could
potentially feel like those great you
know like i feel like pixar really does
this anymore the you know the short
films that play before their feature
films and i feel like that's what all of
these could potentially feel like
what's that alarm john um
six of them all right um but yeah really
came in handy today didn't it john
absolutely always but yeah it really
feels like it could sort of be like that
but uh johnny since you haven't been
here in a while you know
i don't know how to do this uh you know
images no this this looks really fun
obviously a very slight glimpse but uh
yeah like i love the idea we've had you
know the mcu does animation at least
with what-if and we also have the other
shows that are coming up that are more
in the traditional style but i love to
get a glimpse of something like this
that is yeah they're computer animated
they're short forms something that looks
like it'll rest more on physicality than
it will on dialogue and i think that'll
open up some really fun possibilities in
terms of just what they can explore how
much fun they can have and doing so in a
way that's maybe
loosely connected to things but that
doesn't have to be you know a massive
cog or something like this looks like a
cool anthological entry that could you
know connect but also just looks like a
delightfully fun kind of sci-fi
fluffy imaginative time very much so
that was truly the definition of a
teaser yeah you know that is not an
official trailer it does not spoil too
much but it just gives you a glimpse of
what we can expect of course you know
james got involved we know and anything
with group 2 we know there's going to be
a lot of
adorableness and also we get the the
music of course which uh always gets me
ramped up because james gunn really
knows how to he knows how to pick good
tunes so i'm really looking forward to
that but i think you said it best i mean
looks it just looks really adorable and
i'm just really looking forward to
seeing rocket come back as well um and
just seeing the that rock is gonna be in
here i'm pretty sure rock it's going to
be yeah yeah and just seeing the
interact i mean i just that's one of my
favorite and most meaningful
relationships in the mcu is rocket and
groot they just got that uh that
father-son type of relationship and he's
just you know like like a mentor to him
and i'm just really looking forward to
seeing the camaraderie between those two
characters again and the interactions
and i'm just so invested in those two
characters so uh yeah no this looks like
a blast and i just uh i just already i'm
loving the tone from this already and
looking forward to it next month it's
interesting that we're actually getting
this because you know james gunn has
been on record quite a bit saying that
like no after guardians three he's done
he's done with guardians and with that
he's now giving us an i am group show
and you know it's like i was joking
about how it's you know not an official
trailer just easier but they're shorts
so this could serve as an official
trailer when they got five shorts and on
top of that too he's got the guardians
holiday special coming up so he's like i
need to get everything out of my system
so i can officially say bye
to guardians volume three yeah all the
last things
and we need to fill in what happened
with baby groot because i have stories
to tell
and everyone's burning question is the
guardian's holiday special gonna be as
good as the star wars holiday special oh
it's gonna impossible it's gonna be
impossible the top
such such a feat
did vin diesel do the voice for baby
group two yes oh yeah so is vin diesel
returning yes
he's gonna collect those i am groot
checks for the end like till the end of
time like if anybody seems like they
could potentially stay on for the
entirety of their lifetime with a
character it's him and andrew i think
you were the one telling me that there's
going to be
like they're going to be going back to
groot's home planet what was the planet
called yeah they're going back to planet
x which is the uh basically the branch
capital uh where groot is from so it's
going to be interesting to see you know
just seeing kind of not really the
origin tale but just seeing you know
where groot comes from and just you know
how that uh the the planet of uh of his
species so that's gonna be interesting
and fascinating to see in general just
you know just uh how how evolved they
are and just you know how different uh
some of the other species are uh aside
from groot as well
wow wow that's good because it might
actually be more canonically important
than we actually all realize people it's
gonna be the key to guardians this is
the key to everything it ties the
universe together this is what phase
four is all about all right guys well
what did you think of the im groot
trailer leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell leave a like
andrew thanks for being here uh we got
spiderman trailer that we're on the
lookout for that might be up first you
know priorities um but hey before we end
let's do
john you haven't been here in a while
why don't you shout out chase gardner
chase gardner i've been chasing wellness
because i need to talk to you i miss you
man i've missed this whole place but of
all the reject nation of all the super
sexy rejects i know we're not supposed
to pick favorites but you are my
favorite chase
you are chase i am john together we are
united like the tree branches that grow
out of groot at some point i want there
to be no separation between you and me i
don't wanna
know where you end and i begin i just
want us to unite be together and bring
life to the world i mean groot is always
spreading both joy with adorableness but
also
growth and new life and that's what
you're about chase gardner you're the
gardener of this new life of ours
together growing up from the soil of
friendship and camaraderie that's what
the guardians is all about man's about
family vin
diesel i love you man hope you're well i
am groot
i have not missed these in the last two
weeks andrew
i could have just said i am groot for
like two minutes straight actually
[Music]
you